snico just got banned from YouTube they
banned both his personal and his second
Channel at the same exact time and the
first channel didn't even have any
strikes on it which is crazy so it was
100 coordinated attack just to take him
down I'm not you know a sneaker expert I
truly I don't have time to watch all of
snow pumpkin expert I do know my gut
tells me he's a pumpkin yes but two what
have I missed what has he done that
could even be borderline provocative
enough for them to to cancel him what
have I missed was he done what are they
saying what are people what are sneaker
haters saying he did he got banned on
Twitter for telling La son Abby that he
he'll break his face but they were like
going back and forth about potentially
doing a fight together so that's that's
I feel like that's a pretty normal thing
to say basically sneako just said stuff
that doesn't go along with the political
you know typical political agenda so
same reason as like why I don't think
Tate should have been banned obviously
but again it's like he really did
anything wrong you could say as that
sicko did in that video we did that that
you can give fellatio to an infant or
it's okay to have sex with a little girl
if she quote unquote consents but you
can't say to another grown man I'll
break your [ __ ] head like what what
what sick world are we living look at
this so look at this right here this is
another example so Biden thanks Coast
Guard rescue swimmer um that he's
kicking out of the Coast Guard over the
vaccine mandate so I tried to share this
and even just to share something like
this you need to [ __ ] get the real
vaccine info so let's look at let's see
what is the real vaccine covid-19
information center this is the truth
vaselines are thoroughly tested for
safety before they're made available to
the public look at all the cute little
icons you know who this was made by a
marketing department exactly that's the
thing so they'll make something like
fact Checkers put it on a social media
platform and it's similar to how when
you're in a casino and the way that the
floors are designed the color of the
walls everything is extremely deliberate
to get you to spend more money when they
do stuff like this and make the fact
Checker platforms they make it very
simple with clean little Graphics like
this to make it like oh this is just
irrefutable you know what I mean they
have to make it clean
ones are half halfway frankly well yeah
so things need to be made simple which
is also a whole other side thing where
all the laws that are written by
Congress should be made so that the
average person can read it because
that's why people don't read the laws
and just attach to this emotional
nonsense yeah they make it all [ __ ]
all right we can just watch this I
digress we have some breaking news as
YouTuber snico has been completely
banned from the platform both his main
Channel Nico they have been around for
about 10 years and his second channel
shaniko that was really picking up steam
lately have been completely wiped from
the platform itself he shared this email
from YouTube on Instagram today where
they say hi snico we have reviewed your
content and found severe or repeated
violations of our community guidelines
because of this we have removed your
channel from YouTube It's like a badge
of honor nowadays it's it's a badge of
honor to get banned to get banned it
just shows that you're speaking some
truth that they don't want the crazy
thing is that his main Channel his main
Channel actually didn't do anything
wrong at all if anything it was his his
live streaming Channel where he was
getting more um political and saying
stuff that they wouldn't want him to
hear but on his main Channel it was
literally just him making what I would
like to call Art you know very cool
videos absolutely nothing shows that
they also banned his main Channel he
also shared this via his Instagram story
where he says they banned my main
Channel too Nico didn't have any strikes
the thing is guys I'm almost positive
when it comes to YouTube if you get one
channel terminated they usually just
wipe you out across yeah I mean truly
that did the exact same thing
channels YouTube's [ __ ] but if
you're gonna it's the same person if
you're gonna ban their one channel you
ban them all
because I'm telling you guys once you
get one channel terminated you can't
even open a new channel from there
you're pretty much banned from YouTube
the live YouTube I mean consider someone
like leafy is here who tried to start a
new channel time and time again where he
wasn't even necessarily bullying people
anymore and they still got his ass out
of here quickly this comes oh [ __ ] our
face is covering this dude four days
after he was banned from Tick Tock and
something does tell me that his
Instagram page might be going soon as
well this picture is kind of ironic now
because this is the last post he had
before he got banned and I do really
think they're about to give this man the
Andrew Tate treatment and I'm sure a lot
of you guys have known about snico's
channel for years when I was first
coming up in the YouTube scene when I
first kind of started blowing up around
three or four years ago sunico was also
kind of on the rise as well and I'm not
gonna say we're necessarily
contemporaries because we don't really
make a similar style of content but we
did quick algorithm tip you know how we
used to have the DVD logo in the
background this dude has Tom and Jerry
aesthetically pleasing thing on the
screen to keep you mesmerized I think
about the same time was always paying
attention to his channel he's one of the
most creative people on YouTube with his
main Channel snico and he did really
well on that channel for years amassing
over a million subscribers but it seemed
like where snico really struck gold and
where he really had that aha moment was
when he started live streaming and
uploading more like reaction type
content onto his second Channel schnico
and then people start uploading all
these different clips of him on Tick
Tock kind of like with Andrew Tate and
then he became one of the fastest
growing content creators on the whole
platform and I gotta be honest on this
second channel snico was saying some
pretty outlandish [ __ ] he was talking
about a lot of conspiracy theories he
was spitting at Andrew Tate but I would
say even like a little bit more extreme
and almost seemed like the guy was
waking up on a mission to say as much
much Politically Incorrect stuff as
possible every single day and boy did
this man start to ruffle some feathers
with many people making these what are
now like foreshadowing it's hard once
you know the truth and you're watching
this [ __ ] you can't just go back to to
you know believing all of it and spewing
that same old [ __ ] it's hard once
you really pull the curtain back and
look at it to not speak about it you
know and that's exactly what they don't
want you to see it's hard and terrible
and it's also wonderful doing videos
about why sneako should be banned from
the platform altogether hey this is not
gonna be a normal video today I want to
briefly talk about the content creator
sneako and ask YouTube to ban him from
the platform now personally I do have
mixed feelings
YouTube to ban them from the platform
yeah because because Nico made a joke he
said these crazy feminists need to get a
you know have a time with the men wow
it might help because on one hand I do
understand that YouTube is a private
company and obviously they're gonna try
to protect those Advertiser dollars and
when one of your fastest growing content
creators on your platform is saying some
kind of crazy [ __ ] it isn't always the
best look so I can't kind of see how it
would be within the best interests
themselves I've been on YouTube for a
very long time I've seen some really
crazy [ __ ] I've seen content creators
say some really crazy stuff about other
people and almost none of them have ever
got banned I mean I'm talking about
threats I'm talking about getting a doll
of them and using it in as cool manner I
mean I've pretty much seen it all at
this point and yeah we don't even need
to keep watching this we have seen it
all it's all [ __ ] [ __ ] we know
exactly why they're banning them it's
because he's speaking the truth there's
plenty of other creators are out here
promoting stuff that makes you weak and
that's exactly what they want so why
would they ban them with all this stuff
H3 Logan Paul KSI I've done in the past
they didn't get banned they got canceled
and they get spoon fed from from The
Matrix of what to say in the future can
you imagine that maybe trying to spoon
feed us it's the same reason why Biden's
president because he's easy to control
you don't want someone that's gonna that
can't be bought and controlled you know
it doesn't go against the system 100
it's funny because I have no Kamala
Harris fan for the record but just the
other day I was thinking maybe if he
just healed over it would be better to
have her in office because as horrible
as she is she would at least be like
what is this I'm signing like she does
like I give her that credit like like
some synapses might fire in her brain
something might fire where she's asking
questions before she signed [ __ ] I mean
she's dumb enough and lock the people up
I don't care oh she's a lawyer she was a
congresswoman yeah yeah you know she was
a D.A no going out outside 10 p.m
hilarious yeah I mean at least she might
might ask a question whatever it's
horseshit so what she'd be a puppet too
let's get on it let's get Nico on our
stream sneakers coming so we're starting
our like you know more formal podcast
where we really talk with people in just
a couple weeks we are what's today's
date we are it doesn't matter we are
like uh 10 days away from moving into
our home in Florida we're ready it's
ready we're going in and we're going to
be starting so we're gonna we we need to
reach out to him and get him booked for
for our podcast and we're gonna really
have some conversations with that guy
sounds good sounds good maybe if he ever
comes back from Romania he can zap in
from Romania or is he living in Miami
these days where's where's he living
Miami oh so he can just yeah he can just
cruise over sneako you'll get freed one
day don't worry brother yeah he's gonna
get freed because this [ __ ] is not
going they're gonna drive forever
they're gonna drive everyone off of
YouTube to the point where nobody wants
to watch that [ __ ] anymore and
everyone's gonna go to rumble if you
just keep Banning everyone I only watch
Nico Andrew Tate and fresh and fit
really on YouTube so if those three guys
are gone I'm just gonna be on Rumble the
whole time scrolling through their
videos hopefully Rumble fixes their [ __ ]
soon because it looks like buns yeah
just keep getting the word out keep
getting listen I would I we have to I
would guarantee it's like a rumble
behind the scenes right now is like
flying 24 7 building something better I
have I have no doubt they know what's
going on they can read the writing on
the wall and you know what the pendulum
is swinging and Americans I can't speak
for the whole country but for the whole
world but I actually think the whole
world is [ __ ] sick of censorship
we're done we're done even in third
world countries they're coming out and
being like hey cut this [ __ ] we're done
being controlled and you got Elon Musk
making sure that we don't have any dead
zones with regard to internet and and
why and cell service how cool is that
what's that gonna do to the world when
he actually finishes accomplishing that
and everybody has access to free speech
they cannot keep us all down they can't
fire all of you they can't silence all
of you because it's about money and they
know it won't win it's gonna be okay in
the long run gonna be all good it is we
just gotta stay there stay the course
and fight in the meantime we will
persevere keep speaking your minds if
all of us speak our mind they can't shut
us all up also so my Academy drops this
week going into all of my social media
marketing knowledge how to make money on
social media basically everything and I
go crazy in depth I've been working at
this for over a year now adding content
and stuff and I've been cranking at it
so you've been working your ass off kid
yeah I know I'm a G and Mom's making a
section I'm making a section and I've
been working out I've been working out
my section yeah it's gonna be lit it's
actually I'm having a real good time
thank you for inviting me yeah you're
welcome all right thank you guys
[Music]